what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the insane developments in the
demon Slayers story the reverse spoon o
cards continue to be used and we have
the return of some of my favorite
characters so definitely stay tuned for
that if you enjoy these Demon Slayer
chapter reviews the best thing you can
do is smash that like button and share
this video with a friend if you haven't
be sure to subscribe this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future and even say your videos
remember that you can catch these
chapter reviews before they come out on
YouTube if you follow anime up or audio
on Spotify iTunes or wherever else you
listen to podcasts and a big thank you
goes out to our patrons who help make
videos like this one possible more on
you amazing people later for now keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers we
will be talking about the latest demon
singer chapter chapter 197 after all
without further ado let's jump into this
glorious chapter as we remember last
chapter things look super bad for moose
on tundra and Igor oh we're kicking his
butt because Tom Mayo gave him the
perfect poison cocktail many of you in
the comments were saying that tomorrow
was the MVP of last chapter and you're
right Tom on your ichi who saved her
from Mouzon in the first place really
did mess moves on up and their past
actions continue to pose huge problems
for him in the present in the last
chapter time was running out until dawn
and the other demon Slayers were even
recovering this chapter is called
tenacity tenacity is defined as the
quality of being very determined
it also means continuing to exist and
persist in other words tenacity includes
determination and persistence as always
remember to chapter name because it will
be relevant later on the chapter starts
by showing us Tomeo gripping moves ons
body her cells are inside him so this
isn't happening in the physical world
but it's metaphorically showing how it
moves on is trapped by Tom IO his fate
appears to be in Tommy O's hands moves
on looks worried while Tommy yo seems
peaceful and happy because her plan is
working out so well as Tommy o mentions
there is no need for them to be stronger
than moves on in order to kill him
weakening him is good enough I really
like this about demons they're often as
shown then you need to become stronger
in order to overpower your opponent and
people do like seeing two strong
fighters fight and then for the
protagonists to unlock some new
ability or better yet form that he uses
to beat his opponents final and
strongest form this can be very
satisfying to be sure but this approach
often undervalues strategy and
intelligence which I like to see for
demon slayer even if no individual can
become physically stronger than moves on
that doesn't mean that beating him is
hopeless or that they can't find a way
to win they just gotta get creative
thanks to the poison tables have turned
and now we're shown Tom Mayo shoving her
nails into mulan's flesh she says that
just as moves on will do anything to
live the rest of them will do anything
to kill him when it comes to stopping
him everyone is as determined and
persistent as can be then we jump to
some of Milan's thoughts he reflects on
how usually the world means nothing to
him even though the blades of the demon
slayers are bright red like your deep
cheese was Muslim makes it clear that
your eat cheese was on a whole other
level just because they're all bright
red doesn't mean they're equally strong
Mouzon would usually have no problem
generating from the injuries he got from
these demon Slayers and it wouldn't lead
to accumulated exhaustion for him but
thanks to Tommy yo and demon science
experiments there are four drugs in his
system that turned ordinarily
ineffective attacks into extremely
effective attacks that are taking a
physical toll on the demon king of Pop
so it's a two-front battle Tommy owned
her drugs are breaking down moves on
from the inside allowing the demon
slayers on the outside to do so much
more damage than they'd otherwise be
able to do moves on didn't expect that
Tom AO would create such a powerful
poison in so short a time but that's
what she and should know we were able to
accomplish with teamwork
Mulan's arrogance led to a false sense
of security he let down his guard
because he underestimated the others and
now he's paying for it he lets us know
that this poison is completely different
from dolmas and Mouzon has never
encountered it before he reveals that he
needs time to analyze and counteract it
again the manga is emphasizing the idea
that Musa will counteract the poison
which opens up the possibility of moves
on recovering to full strength
we now jump to ton zero who's thinking
that moves on stop because of Tommy O's
poison as he's been doing throughout the
battle he keeps telling himself that he
can do this the demon slayers can win
especially since Millan is so weak now
and it's almost dawn but then things get
crazy
moves on releases what appears to be his
blood demon art it looks like a powerful
electrical discharge like one Pikachu
might release I said he might have
another trick up his sleeve that you
teach he didn't know about and there it
is
the mangaka definitely wanted to
emphasize it because she gave the attack
and its effect two full pages for
everyone constantly asking about his
blood demon art this could very well be
it his body closes up again after the
attack and Tundras in serious pain the
attack messed up his body he can't think
straight he's shocked and apparently
even experiencing seizures he says that
he can't breathe and fears that moves on
will get away this is definitely a new
type of demon attack that can completely
paralyze a demon slayer the crow was hit
by a - and it even affected the young
master at the demon slayer core who was
using the crow to view the battle his
nose is bleeding but he's obviously not
doing as bad as tons you know he says
he's fine and he's more worried about
ego - Anton zero the former flame pillar
suggests that Mouzon may have sensed
their location a tiny detail that may
come into play later it's revealed that
there are only 25 minutes left to go
about the time it takes to watch one
anime episode we jump back to time zero
who wants to get up but he can't he
can't breathe properly and he feels like
the attack crushed his lungs he looks at
moves on and fears that he's going to
get away and then that's when we see in
Ostia make his appearance he cuts a
bunch of massan's tentacles I guess that
he knows game would be one of the first
to recover because of just how much
focus has been placed on his ability to
recover quickly
he knows K and his usual manly way talks
down to moves on telling him that he
won't stand for his behavior it's clear
that his injuries are bad and he's
exhausted but he's still fighting tundra
wants a tally nosce that moves on is too
dangerous but he knows he wouldn't care
even if he could hear him lucky for him
escape moves on is too tired to use his
techniques perhaps you know skating
wouldn't usually stand a chance but
because of the poison and accumulated
damage that moves on has taken he knows
he may very well be able to make a
difference
enos K is clearly touched by the
sacrifice of others and angry that moves
on heard his comrades what is hilarious
about in those kids that he obviously
cares about his fellow demon Slayers but
he doesn't even remember people's names
he talks about how gill may aka the old
guy with the
rosary lost his leg and how Gua K the
guy with the half-and-half holiday lost
his arm he constantly calls Guillaume a
old even though he's just 27 which is
always amusing I commented before that
we didn't get to see nosce shine as much
as any so and cano yet so I really hope
that we'll see noski use an awesome Opie
technique during this fight like Zen he
chose flaming Thunder God attack or
Cano's Vermillion I eNOS he mentions how
the bodies of the people around him
belong to comrades he shared meals with
and that really hits home they're not
just some extras his comrades are the
closest thing he knows he has to family
and moves on killed many and injured the
rest he knows he wants Muslim to do the
impossible
he wants to demon king a pop to give the
lives of those he killed back and to
return yo maze-like and gives arm he
tells Muslim to return everything or
eNOS he will make him pay for it with a
million deaths we see that in escape
even if he doesn't know people's names
is brought to tears because of what they
suffered and the tears start pouring out
of his bore mask
you gotta love eNOS gay unlike kanjuro
who just kept saying he'll when he knows
he with tears in his eyes tells mozart
he'll kill him not once but a million
times he's such a boss that he's willing
to talk down to the strongest demon and
i love it
remember this is the same guy who
dropped one of my favorite quotes when
he said to upper moon to DOMA if hell
doesn't exist I'll create it for you and
there's some truth to what he knows
Cosette the moves on we know that moves
on is a coward and that he'll do
anything to keep on living
holding on desperately to his life
Shakespeare wrote a coward dies a
thousand times before his death but the
valiant taste of death but once it seems
to be most strange that men should fear
seeing that death a necessary end will
come when it will come and quote moves
on because of his extremely long life
and his cowardly ways probably has died
in Shakespeare's sense a million times
while someone brave like mangokuura mu
Ichiro only died once
moves on a taxi nosce in a unique way he
puts his tentacle arm into the ground
and then it comes out below where he
knows he is standing
Mulan's arm which has countless teeth
bites down on in Oscars body and ten
into the air it's quite possible that
only in those cake could survive an
attack like that because of his
flexibility and recovery abilities but
he's still very hurt blood sprays from
him punch I was watching all of this and
he wants to help he no ski but his body
is still shaking and he's not in control
Tundra feels like he'll die before even
a nosegay does then someone else attacks
moves on and what do you know it's my
boys any two hashtags any two hype he's
wide awake and although he sometimes
acted cowardly in the past
he's clearly overcome his fear he's
willing to risk his life in order to
help fight the strongest demon and save
his friends is any to let si nos K know
that he can hear tangelos heartbeat and
that he's still alive
he tells hundreth to focus on staying
alive he says don't die you can't die
this shows how much she cares about time
zero in one panels I need to tell tundra
to survive in three different ways does
I need to tells him that Mexico is gonna
turn human again and tundra is gonna get
her to safety to the house where they
grew up I need to add that Tundras
family is waiting for them to to return
in other words tundra also owes it to
his family that's watching him from
beyond the grave to help make sure that
he and a Zuko survive there's a quote by
Nietzsche that goes like he who has a
why to live can bear almost any how
that's exactly what does that into his
banking on here he's reminding tundra of
his why in order to help him bear the
horrible pain he must be in this whole
time everything tundra did came
originally from the fact that he wanted
to save his sister and can he really
give up now that he's so close
absolutely not is any to get slammed and
this time he knows K helps him it's
insane that he knows he can help after
the way moves on seem to bite his body
in half but that's he knows K for you he
can practically survive anything moves
on slams in those K into a wall and he
spits out some more blood then we get
some important info from Tangier oh he
thinks and I quote if a blood demon art
is attacking my nervous system then a
niche hidden sword just might be
effective end quote he's implying here
that it is Mullins blood demon art
that's doing this to him so this adds
even more weight to the fact that we
finally seen the demon king of pops
demon art after all this time Kendra
wants to stab himself with the
Nietzschean blade hoping
that that will help cleanse his body of
the demon blood despite his paralysis
like state he is able to slowly lift his
sword he stabs himself while trying to
avoid hitting a major blood vessel or
vital spot stabbing yourself with a
sword is never an easy task but you can
bet it's even harder when you can barely
lift a finger and your body is shaking
all over
tundra has no other choice right now so
he goes for it he wonders if it's gonna
work and stop his shaking but we'll have
to wait for the next chapter to find out
chances are though that he didn't stop
himself for nothing
we jumped him moves on and he's in a bad
position he's bleeding and panting
according to him he can't raise his arms
and his body feels extremely heavy he's
furious when he sees that into any nosce
getting up again he thinks about how he
keeps crushing that but they don't die
and they come back again and again they
get up over and over again to buy time
until dawn when they can finally defeat
him this is where the tenacity comes in
they keep surviving and persisting
because they're determined to stop moves
on no matter what happens to them in a
sense they're being framed as monsters
or zombies here because muslim' keeps
giving them really serious injuries and
they just keep getting up and coming at
him again and again it's night at the
living demon slayers and moves on is
definitely afraid we see a leg which
appears to be sana means with all of its
interesting belts he's walking back to
the fight and the fact that we didn't
see anything else leads me to believe
that he might be in really bad shape and
I'm sure we'll figure out how bad in the
next chapter he was shown coming back
using one hand to hold his sword as we
know from one piece and shanks one-armed
swordsman can still be strong and
skilled AF then we are shown Guillaume a
who fought without being able to see
before but now he'll have to fight with
one leg still he's gonna give it all
that he can they're gonna leave it all
on the table holding nothing back no one
is in a good position but things still
look extremely bad for Mouzon there are
less than 25 minutes left now and moves
on apparently can't even lift his arms
moves on also said previously that he
can't use his techniques which implies
that he's too tired to use that move he
used to paralyze tundra and a guru at
this point it's not even about strength
anymore but about endurance who's going
to give up first
who has the most tenacity which is gonna
be the biggest factor in this battle as
always let me know what you think is
gonna happen next in this chapter Musleh
had a secret card to play that seemed to
turn the tables for a second but now
he's in an even worse position where he
can't even lift his arms and the pillars
are coming he's being pushed into a
corner and the question is will
necessity kick in and help moves on
reached some new level of power well a
humanist will show up only to be taken
hostage by Mouzon and why do you think
mulan didn't use his blood demon art
against your Ichi
when he fought him let me know what you
think in the comments just as with the
last chapter we had so many crazy twists
and turns here not only did we get what
appears to be Mullins blood demon art we
also got to see the return of xander -
eNOS K and the pillars meet suti Kanoa
Natsuko the surviving ladies of demon
slayer are the only ones that may still
show up later and that's it for this
review thank you so much for listening
if you enjoyed the review make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demon slayer reviews
remember that you can listen to all of
these demon see reviews before they come
out on youtube if you follow anime up or
audio on spotify itunes or wherever else
you listen to podcasts a special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive YouTube issues and
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Steven and
Greta
Aloha autumn the world stealers the
school bus Tyson quarry no acquired
respect and Pat a heffa and I can't
forget our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Odin Anatoly kazansky alpha
do angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP $30.00 beat Ted no Ted
shelter Joel Staunton very gucci jessica
calif on alicia actor Emperor Taku and
JCC waka
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more by going over
to patreon common lore and becoming a
patron today for as little as one
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course thank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
now if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]